brad keller who has been really good
he has been at his best in his previous
three starts
and the first inning for most of the
year has dictated how he was going to do
in the rest of that game and
we're talking about his last three
starts he has only given up one hit
in the first inning in his last three
starts tim anderson
down he goes on three pitches and one
away
right on the outside part of the blade
he couldn't hold up he got him swinging
beauty and that'll bring up john
monkatta he hit fifth last night
and he lines one to center and taylor
takes a few steps toward left center
field
and there are two down brad keller ready
back he comes
and a ground ball cut off by dozier to
his left
long throw to first is in time so great
start for
brad keller three up three down dylan
cease going the mount for his 21st start
looking for his eighth win as era at 421
a lot of strikeouts 123 of them and 102
and a third the walks not near as many
as last year so
all of those numbers are pretty good
matchups for him whitmerfield will lead
it off
as this is foul first based side and
abreu believes he has a play
he's right leaning against the tarp jose
abreu
for route number one well that's a great
man to keep off base and jose made a
wonderful play
this is very difficult right here he
realizes he's got a shot now he looks
where he
is he sees how much room he has and then
in the webbing of the glove he actually
brings it back
he does this exceptionally well i mean
these are really difficult plays and
he's able to
get it you keep a potential base runner
off base it's the first out of the
inning
everything working out well for jose and
for dylan cease
one down for santana fastball to left
deloitte jimenez his first
chance and he's there to make the catch
so first opportunity nicely done
by eloy who wants to play left field he
feels that he's going to be better
offensively plays left field and
he makes a good play here this ball is
slicing away from him he got a good jump
he runs well
and he makes a catch i mean that was a
very nice play and dylan has certainly
played
two breaking balls two out of the zone
to salvador perez who's one for four
we hit on the ground to the shortstop
that's tim anderson who gloves throws
and gets him
nice work by cease and the white sox
defense
and that'll be another rookie andrew
vaughn
instead a high pop up into shallow right
a long run for three royals and santana
makes the catch jimenez tags that's a
heck of a play
so so far we've seen both first baseman
on each team
make excellent running catches down that
line now you expect o'hearn to catch
that but he's playing him
to the pole side so santana to make that
play
shows me that he's very confident number
one in getting there but his glove
was really good and had that throw been
online it might would have been close
now you roll him up that's a big out for
keller and now runners are at first
and third and it's brian goodwin who
lined into a double play to win last
night's game
goodwin is down on strikes and that's
big with a runner at third in less than
two outs
oh better believe that it's a tough one
it's hard to pick up the rotation if
you're a hitter
it looks fastball but at the last minute
the bottom falls out
so it's the switch hitter larry garcia
and he stays with the fastball and
strikes out garcia on three pitches
so brad keller does a great job of
working around the single and the walk
the socks had two on nobody out come up
empty
the bottom of the second we go no score
100 dozier wants at least a fly ball to
the outfield deep enough to put the
royals in front
one to nothing and there's a fly ball to
center field that will carry
goodwin is back to make the play both
runners will tag
both runners will advance one-nothing
royals as solaire comes down from third
on hunter dozier's sacrifice fly
yes 29th rbi that was clutch way to go
and he's using the whole field falls
down and he says too close for me i'm
going to go ahead and get under it there
very nice he didn't roll over on it now
michael taylor runner it's second two
out
and there's a line drive to the gap but
slicing involved
dropped it two-nothing royals the inning
begins
with a lead-off walk and now an air in
right field for two runs
you never know good swing that was
really a nice one swinging it looks like
that could be a category
oh oops i forgot something that's tough
you know vaughn he'll go back in the
dugout and tell c say i owe the man
sorry about that
and abreu is on to begin the fourth now
alloy
jimenez to swing ground ball short lopez
gets into second for one on the first
and that
is another double play and carlos
santana
he started towards the dugout and was
about 10 steps from the dug and realized
oh there was nobody out so that's only
two out
rather than three out very nicely done
it was almost a tailor-made double play
as
lopez underhanded the baseball to
whitmer field and whit
turned and threw a strike to carlos
santana gavin sheets who walked on
10 pitches in the second inning
oh gavin sheets gives it a ride into
right field
bring him home that ball was thrilled
he can get one up in the air it's gone
he's got tremendous power
the whole first at-bat he was looking
for that low fastball something that he
could drive
he didn't get it he filed off a lot of
good pitches finally taking a walk and
this time
he got it he got it middle in and down
and puts a charge into it and just like
that
sucks cut the lead in half and that was
a blast royals would love to get some
tack on runs the 1-0 to hearn is pulled
to the right side
and that's going to get through here
comes ben attendee around third base
he will score and the royals take a 3-1
lead on ryan o'hearn's 19th rbi
so a strikeout then a double then a
single
and the royals have their two run lead
back michael taylor
3-1 3-1 slider to left field and lloyd
reaches down and he made the
catch eloy jimenez a major play in this
game
to take away a hit from taylor he's
played a great left field two terrific
catches a great throw
he takes that one right off the grass i
mean what a play that was
yikes to me he looks more athletic in
left field than we've seen him in the
past
the bottom of the sixth inning the
middle of the
royals order solaire swinging a ground
ball to the first baseman abreu he'll
pick it up and he'll
take it to the bag ben and tendy who
attacked the first pitch
twice same spot strike three an echo of
strike two and two gone
that time he threw the ball exactly
where he wanted to it was some high fast
balls a cornucopia of high fastballs as
a matter of fact and he threw it right
by him
oh hearn here it is swinging a miss he
struck him out
he's got six punch outs you
gotta believe this is the last batter
for brett's
on the ground at second base that'll get
a run home so it's three to two
garcia scores angle to third now a wild
one would tie the ball game with a
brayyou coming up
abrayu on now he's got runners at the
corners for lloyd jimenez
angle the tying run abreu the go-ahead
run
jimenez do not walk
anyone in front of him wow
welcome back hi mom see you later five
three it's a noise night anyway dyson
with two outs
three and two dyson pops it up
liam says it's in the sky of rayu's
underneath and a basket catch
on the night eloy jimenez trumpeted his
return to major league baseball
the sox win it thanks to him five to
three